>> Harnarayan: AND THE FIRSTAKE.
FAKE RIGHT THERE.
YOU DO A HEAD FAKE LIKE THIS,MA.
HE'S IN ALONE AND MIKE SMITH
FORCED TORRIE.
TRIED TO CHIP IT OUT OF THE TRIO
MONAHAN GETS THE PUCK TO DUBE.
GETS IT RIGHT BACK.
A PASS TO THE MIDDLE.
MONAHAN NOW GETS THE SHOT OFF.
REBOUND
TTLING WITH
MATTHEW TKACHUK.
McDAVID GETS IN  A GOAL!
ONE-TIMER.
PULJUJARVI OUT OFCOMES FREE TO .
DARNELL
DANGLES.
EXTENDS TO THE FAR POST TO DENY.
GAUDREAU IN FRONT!
TKACHUK WITH A MM
SHORTHANDED OPPORTUNITY.
YAMAMOTO TO THE NET.
BOUCHARD MAKAK
3-0 EDMONTON.ETS GOOD WOOD ON IP
ON EDGE A LITTLE BIT UP OVER TOP
LET'S FACE IT, EARLY ON THEY
WERE ALL OVER EDMONTON.
THEY JUST COU
REBOUND!
THE FLAMES SCORE THEIR FIRST
GOAL OF THE SEASON!
THANKSUGE SHIFT FOR THE
CALGARY FLAMES DOWN BY THREE.
THEY NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING
HAPPEN FO HYMAN! LOOKING TOND TY
FLAMES ARE WITHIN OROUND.
HE'S READY FOR THIS PASS.
RIGHT IN THE BACK OF THE NET.
ONE-GOAL GAME.HEAD.
PULJUJARVI SHOOTS AND HE SCORESN
PULJUJARVI WITH AN EXCELLENT OP.
VALIMAKI TO MONAHAN WITH SOME
SEAN MONAHAN LOOKININ
FOEGELE STEALS.
QUICK
OTHER WAY. THE
OTHER END.
PASS TO MANGIAPANE.
VALIMA